fake news könnten schon bald der
vergangenheit angehören sollte
nachrichten können nämlich eigentlich
relativ einfach entlarvt wären wäre da
nicht die unglaubliche datenmenge im
internet die dazu bewältigen ist doch da
kann jemand oder etwas helfen die
künstliche intelligenz wie das geht und
wie es heute schon ausprobiert werden
kann was jetzt endlich zum seitenwechsel
herzlich willkommen bei der
amerikanischen präsidentschaftswahl 2016
ist das thema so präsent wie noch nie
informationen verbreiten sich in
sekundenschnelle um den ganzen globus
dabei werden oftmals lügen für bare
münze verkauft dabei haben fake news
eine lange tradition schon die alten
pharaonen logan dass sich die balken
bogen damals war es aber auch noch super
simpel man musste einfach nur irgendeine
behauptung aufstellen so hatte zum
beispiel ramses der zweite gemacht er
hatte 1274 vor christus den krieg die
etr verloren zurückgekommen verkündete
er den weg und ließ ihn in stein meißeln
quasi eine der ersten fake news in stein
gehauen
heute ist es viel einfacher oder auch
schwerer alles ist digital überall sind
zeugen aber andererseits ist das
internet großer verzeigt hier soll jetzt
die künstliche intelligenz helfen fake
news zu finden mit software wäre es
nämlich zumindest möglich die großen
datenmengen zu durchforsten aber was
kann die software was ein mensch nicht
kann woran können fans erkannt werden
dafür hat das deutsche forschungszentrum
für künstliche intelligenz kurz gfk eine
idee entwickelt wie fans schnell und
zuverlässig aufgespürt werden können
aber ist der ansatz ganz einfach er baut
darauf auf was auch schon ramses der
zweite gemacht hat gute news also
qualitativ hochwertige news haben immer
auch ein bild dabei brandes war es ein
stein regiert durch das auslesen
verschiedenster merkmale soll jetzt
manipulierter bilder in zukunft erkannt
werden
die software läuft dabei im hintergrund
und gibt eine warnung aus sobald
verdächtigen bilder beim surfen im
internet erkannt werden zitat die
funktionsweise des systems beruht auf
der annahme dass das bildmaterial
bereits zu einem früheren zeitpunkt in
einem anderen zusammenhang publiziert
wurde erklärte sarah lkw die
entwicklerinnen des prototyps zitat mit
einer infizierten bildersuche werden
zunächst die ähnlichsten fotos gesucht
und während zeitstempel überprüft anhand
der übereinstimmung und den verknüpften
datum lässt sich feststellen ob das bild
eventuell von einem früheren ereignis
stamm zitat ende
und das beste es ist ein browser plugin
das heißt jeder pc user mit einem chrome
browser kann es installieren allerdings
kleine einschränkungen aktuell handelt
es sich bei dem addon noch um einen
prototypen wir müssen uns
also noch ein wenig gedulden bis das
ganze für alle verfügbar sein wird
natürlich halten wir euch über dieses
thema und über alle anderen themen mir
auf dem laufenden der medien nicht
erwartet man hier genau ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke wenn ihr klingt ungefähr noch
nicht abonniert habe dann habt ihr das
hier verpasst die besten videos von
pixum science fiction und ansonsten
bestand bleibt dran